>> THE WHITE HOUSE EITHER HAS NO
CLUE WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE
BORDER OR THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
KNOW HOW BAD IT IS.
THEY'VE BEEN STONEWALLING THE
MEDIA ON THE NUMBER OF HAITIAN
MIGRANTS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FINALLY
RELEASING NUMBERS.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY DON'T ADD
UP.
>> THERE ARE 15,000 MIGRANTS
UNDER THE DEL RIO BRIDGE
SATURDAY.
IF YOU ADD UP THE ONES YOU SAY
WERE EXPELLED, IT IS LESS THAN
5,000.
WHERE'S EVERYBODY ELSE?
>> I'M HAPPY TO GET YOU A MORE
FRUITFUL RUNDOWN FOR YOU IF IT'S
HELPFUL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> INSTEAD OF FIXING THE MESS IN
DEL RIO, THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
IS REPEATING FALSE LEFT WING
TALKING POINTS BY RUNNING WILD
WITH A COMPLETELY BOGUS
NARRATIVE THAT AGENTS ON HORSE
BACK WERE WHIPPING HAITIAN
MIGRANTS.
THEY'VE COME UP WITH A SOLUTION,
TAKE AWAY THE HORSES.
>> WE FEEL THE IMAGES ARE
HORRIFIC.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CONVEYED WILL
HAPPEN QUICKLY.
I CAN CONVEY TO YOU THE
SECRETARY ALSO CONVEYS TO CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS EARLIER THIS
MORNING THAT WE WOULD NO LONGER
BE USING HORSES IN DEL RIO.
>> WHY ISN'T THE PRESIDENT
TELLING PEOPLE TO GO?
THESE IMAGES THAT PEOPLE SAY ARE
WRONG.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE AWAY THAT
HIS ACTIONS MADE CLEAR HOW
HORRIBLE AND HORRIFIC HE THINKS
THESE IMAGES ARE.
>> AS OPPOSED TO THE IMAGES
WE'VE BEEN SHOWING YOU FOR
MONTHS.
WHILE DEMOCRATS SMEAR BORDER
PATROL AGENTS AS RACIST, A
REPORTER CAUGHT THIS MOMENT THAT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF THAT
NARRATIVE.
>> I'D LIKE TO SHOW YOU ANOTHER
VIDEO WHERE WE SAW ONE MAN
STARTS TO BE SWEPT DOWN THE
RIVER.
HE WAS CLEARLY NOT A GOOD
SWIMMER.
SEVERAL HAITIAN MIGRANTS WENT IN
AFTER HIM TO TRY AND HELP HIM.
ULTIMATELY, IT WAS THE BORDER
PATROL, SEVERAL AGENTS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE RIVER, WHO
TOOK A LINE, THREW IT INTO THE
RIVER AND THEY WERE ULTIMATELY
ABLE TO HELP THAT MAN, THAT
MIGRANT GET OUT OF THE WATER.
>> ARE YOU SURE HE WASN'T TRYING
TO WHIP THAT GUY WITH THAT VERY
VERY VERY LONG ROPE?
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT LOOKS LIKE SLAVERY RIGHT
THERE.
DANA, YOU HAVE HORRIFIC IMAGES
GOING ON FOR MONTH, TOTAL CHAOS
AT THE BORDER.
WHAT DOES THE WHITE HOUSE DO?
BAN HORSES.
PROBLEM SOLVED.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE MADDENING
THINGS I HAVE EVER SEEN.
THEY MISUNDERSTOOD AN IMAGE.
THEY OVERREACTED TO IT.
AND IN ORDER TO BACK FILL AN
COVER THEMSELVES, INSTEAD OF
SAYING, SORRY, WE DIDN'T MEAN TO
IMPUGN THE BORDER PATROL.
THEY SAID, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR BEST RESOURCE.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT'S THE
BEST RESOURCE BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO CODDLED AND SHELTERED.
THEY CAN'T GO TO THE BORDER.
>> THEY HAVE BORDER PRIVILEGE.
YOU HAVE NEW YORK REPORTERS WHO
HAVE NO IDEA WHY THE HORSES ARE
THERE BECAUSE YOU HAVE ROUGH
UNEVEN TERRAIN.
>> I EVEN KNOW HOW TO TURN A
HORSE LIKE THAT.
YOU USE IT AS A TOOL.
THESE HORSES ARE SUCH A
RESOURCE.
SO NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THESE
GUYS, THEY'RE BEING BENCHED.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE DESK DUTY.
THEY CAN'T EVEN DO THEIR JOB.
IT REALLY MAKES ME BAD.
>> SAY DANA WAS HERE.
I WENT IN HERE FOR A SNIP.
THAT CREATED AN IMAGE THAT I WAS
KISSING DANA PERINO.
FOX WOULD FIRE ME OR SUSPEND ME,
PUT ME ON PAID LEAVE.
HOPEFULLY, PAID LEAVE.
OVER AN IMAGE THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS IS FAKE?
I DIDN'T KISS DANA.
I MERELY SNIFFED HER PERFUME.
CONCERNED ABOUT AN IMAGE, NOT
THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH IS SO OBVIOUS THERE
WAS NO WHIPPING GOING ON.
BIDEN APPOINTED HARRIS BECAUSE
HE NEEDED A BUFFER FOR ALL THIS.
SHE DID THE FAKE THING.
GO FIND OUT ROOT CAUSES.
EVERYTHING GOT WORSE.
SHE COMES BACK, I'M DONE.
PROBLEM'S STILL THERE.
NOW EVERYONE'S LOOKING AT JOE,
RIGHT?
JOE, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
JOE IS NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING FOR
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS.
JOE'S NOW SAYING THE SYSTEM'S
BROKEN.
JOE BROKE THE SYSTEM.
HE GOT RID OF CATCH AND RELEASE,
THE WALL.
CAPPED THE ICE PEOPLE.
NO MORE DEPORTATION.
HIS POLICY IS CATCH AND RELEASE.
JOE BIDEN IS THE SYSTEM.
HE'S BEEN IN THE SYSTEM FOR 40
YEARS.
HE'S BEEN VP FOR EIGHT.
HE CAN, AT THE STROKE OF HIS
PEN, GET RID OF ALL THIS.
WHERE DID ALL THE MONEY GO TO
HAITI, GERALDO?
IN 2010, SENT KIDS $5 BILLION.
DIDN'T GO TO THE HAITIANS,
GERALDO.
DOES JOE CARE?
JOE DOESN'T EVEN CARE ABOUT
THAT.
MAYORKAS SAID THE BORDER'S
CLOSED, KATIE.
IT'S NOT CLOSED IF YOU LET HALF
THE PEOPLE IN THAT YOU CATCH.
THAT'S LIKE IF YOU AND I WENT TO
A PARTY AND THE BOUNCER SAID,
PARTY'S OVER, THEN LET US IN.
PARTY'S NOT OVER.
PARTY'S JUST GETTING STARTED,
KATIE.
SO THAT MAKES NO SENSE.
SCHUMER COMES OUT, LETS THE
TRUTH SLIP.
WE NEED MIGRATION AND AMNESTY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LABOR SHORTAGE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
THEY NEED THE CHEAP LABOR
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEIR DONORS
WANT.
CRYING CHUCK WANTS THE VOTE.
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
>> JUST NO SNIFFING.
>> THE THING IS, ONE THING THAT
GETS ME, KATIE, THE WHITE HOUSE
DID NOT REACT TO THE BORDER
CRISIS UNTIL THEY FOUND SOMEBODY
TO PUNISH.
IT WAS JUST A WHITE GUY ON A
HORSE.
THAT'S WHO WAS ACCEPTABLE TO
MAXINE WATERS AND THE SQUAD AND
EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS CRISIS FOR
YEARS WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
POLICIES UNTIL THEY CAN BLAME
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS DOING
THE JOB OUTLINED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
USING THE HORSE THE WAY IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE
WAS STOPPING THESE ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS THE ORDER
DISOBEYING ORDERS.
THIS COMES DOWN TO AN ISSUE OF
TRUST.
IF THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS
WILLING TO CHANGE A POLICY LIKE
THIS AND PUT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS IN EVEN MORE DETRIMENTAL
SITUATIONS AND SET THEM UP TO
FAIL MORE THAN THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY, BASED ON A LIE, WHAT
ELSE ARE THEY CAPABLE OF DOING?
THIS WAS AN EMOTIONAL DECISION
DRIVEN BY HYSTERIA AND FALSE
NARRATIVES ON TWITTER.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
DEMOCRATS ARE CONSTANTLY TURNING
THE GOOD GUYS, BORDER PATROL,
POLICE, INTO BAD GUYS TO BENEFIT
THIS EMOTIONAL AGENDA.
THEY NEED A DISTRACTION FROM
THIS REAL CRISIS, CATASTROPHE.
AL SHARPTON WAS AT THE BORDER
TODAY.
WHY DO YOU THINK MAXINE WATERS
HAD THIS PRESS CONFERENCE?
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS ABOUT
RACE.
WHEN THEY MAKE IT ABOUT RACE,
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE FAILED
POLICIES.
CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE THREAT TO
AMERICANS NOT TESTING FOR COVID
OR CRIMINALS TAKING OVER BUSES
AND INJURING OUR ICE OFFICERS.
RIGHT?
NEXT DHS IS GOING TO RELEASE
THEIR INVESTIGATION TO THESE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO WERE
DOING THEIR JOB.
SOUNDS LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE
WANTS THEM TO BE PUNISHED.
LISTEN TO JEN PSAKI.
WE FEEL THOSE IMAGES ARE
HORRIFIC.
WE FEEL THEY ARE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT GIVING INTO AN
EMOTIONAL NARRATIVE.
JUST GOING TO GET WORSE.
>> GERALDO, REPUBLICANS GET A
LOT OF THINGS WRONG.
REPUBLICANS HAVE FLAWS.
THERE'S A BIG FLAW WITH
DEMOCRATS.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU WOULD
AGREE WITH THIS.
THEY ALWAYS PIT ORDER AND
PROCESS ON THE OPPOSITE END OF
COMPASSION.
IF YOU DESIRE ANY KIND OF
PROCESS OR ORDER, SOMEHOW YOU
ARE COLD AND NONEMPATHETIC.
SO WHAT YOU END UP HEARING IS
THE ULTIMATE RESULT, CHAOS,
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET HURT.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> I GUESS IT DOES.
I STILL AM HORRIFIED BY THAT
IMAGE.
I HATE TO SAY THAT.
I KNOW THAT IT IS NOT THE
SUBSTANTIVE HEART OF THIS
MATTER.
I WORRY THAT BECAUSE OF THE
HORSE AND BECAUSE OF THE IMAGE
SO VIVID, WE AREN'T
CONCENTRATING ON WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
THIS IS ABOUT HAITI.
HAITI HAS GONE TO HELL IN A HAND
BASKET SINCE THE EARTHQUAKE OF
2010 WHERE I WATCHED HILLARY
CLINTON MISUNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN HAITI THERE ON THE
RUNWAY IN PORT-AU-PRINCE.
THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN SKEWED BY
THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM FOR
GENERATIONS.
CUBANS GETTING MOST FAVORED
NATION.
CUBANS IN FLORIDA, THEY GET
ASYLUM.
HAITIANS TOUCH THE SAND IN
FLORIDA THEY GET DEPORTED.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A HUGE
HYSTERICAL OVERREACTION TO THESE
HAITIANS.
YOU TALK AS IF THERE'S BEEN THIS
INK STAIN SWEEPING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THAT,
GERALDO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SHANTY
TOWN.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
THAT'S THE IMAGE THAT'S SHOCKING
PEOPLE, NOT THE GUY ON HORSE
BACK.
>> THAT IMAGE --
>> THAT'S ALSO SIX DAYS LATER
FROM 15,000.
>> THIS IS ONE THIRD OF WHAT IT
WAS.
>> BECAUSE THEY GOT LET IN.
>> SO WHAT THEY GOT LET IN.
>> ANYBODY GETS TO COME HERE,
GERALDO?
THAT'S THE ATTITUDE JOE BIDEN
HAS.
>> YOU'RE ACTING LIKE IT WAS AN
ARMY OF HAITIANS.
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT AN
ARMY.
DON'T PUT WORDS IN MY MOUTH.
YOU'RE DOING WHAT JOE BIDEN
DOES.
I'M ABOUT TO SMELL YOU, GERALDO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THAT WILL BE TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT AND YOU'LL GET ON PAID
LEAVE WHICH I WIL